[Music]
[Music]
but the pace of progress
is too slow in fact we are now facing a
backlash
on basic women's rights just think about
the istanbul convention on violence
against women several eu countries have
not yet
ratified the convention others are
talking about getting out of it
and this is totally unacceptable
while we keep pushing against this trend
i will put forward together with my
college that is gender balanced
we will put forward new legislation by
the end of the year
a law to combat violence against
women from prevention to protection
and prosecution online and offline
and we will propose to add all forms
of hate crime to the list of crimes
spelled out in the european union
treaties
and this includes violence against women
as well as hate crimes against lgbtiq
people because freedom from
fear is the most basic
of rights and it must be guaranteed for
all whatever their gender whomever they
love
generation equality means much
more than protection from violence it
also means
quality education for girls support to
women entrepreneurs
expanding sexual and reproductive health
rights the european union's new budget
for foreign policy will contribute
to these goals and you ask to be
concrete
it was just approved and this part of
the budget is worth
79 billion euros at least
85 of the new actions will contribute to
gender equality
and at least 4 billion euro will be
specifically dedicated
to women's and girls rights and
empowerment
these investments and actions will
contribute to this forum's global
acceleration plan
this is concrete action for generation
equality
diversity makes us richer
the world that we build for the next
generation
should not just be greener and more
digital
but also more equal and more diverse
so that the next generation of women
will truly be
generation equality let's work for this
together
and i really thank you for your
attention this wonderful meeting thanks
a lot